[Música]
el pasado 22 de marzo el diario el
espectador de colombia cumplió
exactamente
135 años de circulación un periódico de
oposición fundado en 1887 por fidel
lezcano gutiérrez con el fin de defender
en ese entonces la libertad y también
las garantías ciudadanas su legado sigue
inspirando a las nuevas generaciones de
periodistas que llegan al espectador con
nuevas formas de pensar y narrar como
varios segmentos que tienen en sus
plataformas como la pulla por ejemplo el
lema de estos 135 años es periodismo con
coraje y coraje es el que han tenido
para poder sortear una serie de hechos
que ha marcado la historia de ese
periódico que hablamos con nuestro
segundo invitado del día él es fiel cano
él es el director del diario el
espectador de colombia fidel buena
mañana feliz viernes gracias por estar
aquí con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 hola buenos días le quiero
preguntar entonces don fidel como ha
hecho el periódico para estar estos 135
años circulando incluso todavía impreso
qué significa este hito para ustedes
pues muy significativo imagínese un
periódico que ha sufrido tantos
contratiempos que han tratado de callar
tantas veces desde su propia fundación
pues esto bonito que llegue a 135 años y
yo diría que lo que lo ha sostenido pues
es la coherencia con ese
mandato digamos del de su fundador
haber creado un periódico liberal cuando
las ideas liberales estaban proscritas
en este país y había muy poco espacio
para la libertad de prensa
y creo que ese norte lo hemos protegido
durante estos 135 años no ha sido fácil
pero por eso llegamos hasta acá creo que
se ha vuelto un periódico o un medio
necesario para los colombianos y ellos
son los que lo han protegido ante tantos
ataques hablaba de la libertad de prensa
difícil no en nuestra actualidad también
en nuestros países como han hecho
ustedes para seguir con esa libertad
para que no se callen las ideas
recordemos de estos momentos históricos
del periódico el incidente de 1952 el
ataque con una bomba en 1989 el
asesinato de don guillermo cano en
1986 todo esto en contra la libertad de
la prensa que tanto ha cambiado o si es
que ha cambiado no ha cambiado mucho no
pues no digamos que el ataque violento
[Música]
de esos hechos que acabas de narrar pues
no es igual hoy en día pero existen todo
tipo de presiones nuevas más
sofisticadas además para tratar de minar
la credibilidad de los medios y todo
este tipo de cosas que se utilizan hoy
para tratar de acallar las voces pero
bueno yo creo que insisto que un
periodismo hecho de manera seria de
manera transparente
pues finalmente tiene que prevalecer lo
sea
ante todos los intentos de acallar las
voces pues éstas se hacen más fuertes y
siempre hay una audiencia y una
ciudadanía que protege esas voces cómo
hacer para trabajar en un contexto como
el colombiano digamos una historia de
violencia en el país un conflicto armado
además lo sacó colación porque tenemos
estas elecciones presidenciales aquí
nomás a la vuelta en el mes de mayo como
hacen ustedes también para para cubrir
todos estos eventos importantes en el
país para protegerse y también para
sortear esta serie de desinformación que
ahora circula muchísimo por las redes
sociales la importancia que tienen
entonces los medios de comunicación para
que se sepa realmente la verdad los
hechos objetivos y no caer en la
desinformación
internet es un escenario difícil este no
es un país fácil para ejercer el
periodismo creo que el periodismo
colombiano no solo el del espectador
realmente tiene una gran altura digamos
de él y lo ha hecho con mucha valentía y
con mucho coraje también
y yo creo que esa es la esencia del
periodismo y la esencia de un medio como
el espectador pues es no callarse y no
dejarse doblegar ante todos los intentos
de los poderosos para pues para que la
voz no sea libre y eso es lo que nos ha
sostenido y si no es fácil como tú bien
dices pero creo que hay que persistir si
uno cree en el valor de la buena
información y el trabajo periodístico
también tienen trabajos periodísticos
irreverentes abriendo la puerta a gente
joven a nuevo periodismo también con
mucha libertad de expresión que es muy
importante en la prensa como hacen
ustedes para pues tener eso también
además para sostener un periódico con
una publicidad para para que la prensa
escrita siga digamos vida en un mundo
tan digital como el que tenemos ahora
pues un poco es eso la transformación
digital que ha vivido en el periódico
que está sobre los mismos ejes no de qué
manera nosotros trasladamos esa esencia
del espectador de ese periodismo
centenario a los nuevos usos de la
información de qué manera cambiamos los
es cambiamos la manera de acercarnos sin
comprometer pues la seriedad de nuestro
periodismo y eso es el ejemplo pues más
exitoso que desde el de la pulla pero
tenemos varios otros donde pues el
espectador toda la vida durante estos
135 años se ha atrevido a innovar a
equivocarse también ya echar reversa
cuando toque
de manera que estamos en ese proceso y
lo vamos a seguir haciendo por supuesto
por delante la libertad la voz libre
creo que eso es una esencia del
espectador ha sido siempre y eso es lo
que me sobre lo que se basan todos estos
nuevos formatos y nuevos experimentos
que vivimos haciendo cada rato en el
espectador con fidel le quiero preguntar
si estos experimentos y esta libertad
con coraje que ustedes tienen digamos y
sacó el coraje por estos 135 años no
afecta a lo mejor la publicidad de los
grandes grupos del país los grandes
grupos que manejan las empresas pues la
política
y bueno hay de todo en el mundo
publicitario
lamentablemente digamos que creo yo que
la inversión publicitaria tiene que ser
mucho más consciente de dónde pone su
dinero no solamente buscando un
beneficio digamos comercial sino también
lo que significa el periodismo para la
nación en la que hacen sus negocios
el buen periodismo digamos entonces creo
que ahí estamos dando la lucha a todos
los medios por supuesto hoy en día pues
puede ser más efectivo darle la plata a
un influencer que va a decir lo que tú
quieres que digan sobre tu marca que
poner la plata en un
un periodismo serio digamos y
equilibrado que no se vende digamos a lo
que quiera el quien pone el dinero
entonces sigue es más difícil conseguir
la plata sin duda además pues están los
grandes gigantes en el mundo digital que
se llevan la gran porción de la plata de
la publicidad entonces lo que lo que
hemos trabajado mucho en el espectador
es devolverle el valor a la información
de qué manera la gente y las audiencias
aprenden la diferencia que hace un buen
periodismo en una sociedad y aprenden a
bueno a contribuir para que ese
periodismo perviva hasta cuando ustedes
tienen pensado ir impresos digamos esto
es para los amantes de los periódicos y
empresas en este mundo tan digitalizado
que cada vez tenemos o menos papel cada
vez las personas prefieren no sé un
dispositivo como éste una tablet o un
teléfono para informarse tienen pensado
una caducidad o hasta cuando pues la
gente deje de comprarlo como como pueden
manejar eso sí yo creo que es digamos es
un producto que por supuesto uno puede
aspirar a que tenga la masividad que
tenía antes pero de todos modos es una
experiencia y consumo de información
diferente
empaquetada digamos es una edición
pensada de comienzo a fin que es muy
distinta
a la velocidad digamos de la información
que se mueve en el mundo digital
entonces creo que son plataformas
diferentes y hay que
aprovechar lo que ofrece cada una de
esas plataformas
no no me quita el sueño digamos si el
plan si el periódico impreso va a
persistir uno
curiosamente después de la pandemia en
todo el mundo se ha dado el proceso de
no solo de confiar en la mejor
información sino también los periódicos
impresos en general han vuelto a revivir
en su circulación nosotros lo hemos
visto hemos subido suscripciones del
impreso durante los últimos años sí
entonces creo que es pronto para
decretar la muerte pero seguramente será
un un producto posiblemente solo de
suscripción digamos como más exclusivo
que en la masividad
pues bien gracias por su tiempo por
estar con nosotros aquí en directo
américa de france 24 un gran abrazo
muchas gracias a ustedes